Thanksgiving was Maria's favorite holiday.
Her whole family came to visit.
And there was always lots of good food to eat.
Maria's mom and grandmother made turkey and tamales.
Aunt Carla brought the stuffing.
Aunt Liz brought black beans.
And Uncle Carlos brought sweet potato pie.
After dinner, the women talked.
The men watched football.
And the kids played games.
But this Thanksgiving, there was a snowstorm.
Nobody could come.
"Thanksgiving is ruined,"
said Maria.
Maria and her family went outside.
They saw some of their neighbors.
Their neighbors were unhappy, too.
"I was going to go to my son's house,"
said Mr. Lee.
"I made sticky rice, but no turkey."
"I was going to go to my sister's house,"
said Mrs. Florio.
"I made my special pasta and homemade bread. But no turkey."
"I don't have turkey, either,"
said Ms. White.
"My mother was going to bring it. All I have is pumpkin pie."
Suddenly Maria got an idea.
She whispered her idea to her mom.
"What a wonderful idea,"
said Mom.
"We have turkey,"
Maria told the neighbors.
"Please come to our home for Thanksgiving dinner,"
said Mom.
So they did.
There was lots of good food to eat.
Maria felt thankful for her family, for good food, and for good neighbors.